why hi there welcome to Kiel I'm a
student here but I've got the day off
and would like to explore the city with
you come on
you can see how wonderful it is the
fresh breeze the salt air of the
seagulls it's great to be able to get so
close to the seals
they're so cute this is actually an
aquarium but there's a public area where
you don't have to pay admission I think
it's really nice to watch the seals
swimming around outside and so close to
the sea it's special
his heel is a really beautiful city and
it has a lovely atmosphere right now
we're on the Danish Casa the only Street
in the old town it's so quaint I like it
a lot you can admire historic old
buildings
look that's the townhall I think it must
be the only spot where you can look at
Keele from above
that's great up here too bad it's
raining but it rains all the time and
cue the weather's always changing
I'm gone you can see for cruise ships
right now - over there - over there
that's cool
the city's really crowded today it's
usually pretty empty I guess they're all
from the ships it's so crowded I get the
feeling the city is going to burst
oh yes now I'd like to have a Kia
Connect post
I don't can I have a cake necklace why
is it called that because it snaps oh
thank you when you take a bite you'll
see
I did snap
as it's so beautiful here you have a
great view of the Baltic and you can see
a couple of lighthouses over there
here we are finally at laboux Beach it's
really nice here but it's a little windy
you can see the beach and the Wicker
beach chairs they're very attractive
so here I'll say goodbye from up here on
the leopard naval Memorial with its
beautiful view I hope you've had as much
fun as I have I had a wonderful day in
Kiel thanks and bye